NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANT R. IT ARMS WILL
HEAR THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN
ARAM BELA.
BAKER. BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRAVO.
BURKE. KILEY AERO.
CALDERONE CORREO SERVAN TEN AS
TRIAL.
CHAVEZ
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY.
COOPER. CUNNINGHAM SALLY. DAILY
EGGMAN FLORA.
PHONE
FRAZIER FREED MEN. GALLAGHER
CASINO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY. GRAY SEN HARPER HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KILEY LACKEY LEVINE THE
MOAN. LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NECESARIA EN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL. PATTERSON
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
RARE IS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALA'S
SANTIAGO STEINORTH STONE. THEIR
MEN.
TEEN BOTH PAL.
WALDRON WEBER. WOULD. MISTER
SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER TO
PLEASE RISE FOR TODAY'S
INVOCATION. THE DAYS PER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND BOB LUCIA.
REDNOSEDAY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
FIVE DAYS AGO ON THE MORNING OF
SATURDAY JANUARY THIRTEENTH. AN
ALERT WAS SENT OUT OVER
TELEVISION AND RADIO AND CELL
PHONES TO THE RESIDENTS OF
HAWAII.
THE MESSAGE READ BALLISTIC
MISSILE THREAT INBOUND TO
HAWAII.
SEEK IMMEDIATE SHELTER.
THE ALERT ENDED WITH THE WORDS
THIS IS NOT A DRILL.
MY COUSIN WHO WORKS FOR THE
HONOLULU POLICE DEPARTMENT.
TEXTED ME THAT DAY TO SHARE THE
DISBELIEF. AND THE RELIEF THAT
THEY FELT WHEN THIRTY MINUTES
THIRTY EIGHT MINUTES LATER. A
SECOND MESSAGE WAS SENT
SIGNALING FALSE ALARM.
HOW WOULD WE FEEL? AND WHAT
WOULD WE THINK IF WE WERE TOLD
WE MIGHT HAVE ONLY MINUTES TO
LIVE.
IN AUGUST OF NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX
TWO YEARS AFTER I CAME TO
SACRAMENTO.
THERE WAS A HORRIFIC PLANE CRASH
OF A JAPAN AIRLINES SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN PASSENGER JET.
IT WAS THE COMMUTER FLIGHT GOING
FROM JAPAN'S TO MAJOR CITIES OF
TOKYO TO OSAKA.
TWELVE MINUTES MINUTES AFTER
TAKEOFF. THERE WAS A
CATASTROPHIC MALFUNCTION.
AND THE FIVE HUNDRED NINE
PASSENGERS WERE TOLD TO PREPARE
FOR CRASH LANDING.
THERE WERE ONLY FOUR SURVIVORS.
BACK THEN I SUBSCRIBE TO THE
STILL LEAGUES'S STING LIFE
MAGAZINE.
LIFE MAGAZINE HAD AN
UNFORGETTABLE ARTICLE THAT
FOCUSED ON HASTILY WRITTEN NOTES
FOUND SCATTERED THROUGHOUT THE
CRISIS I.
THE PASSENGERS WERE.
PREDOMINATELY COMMUNING
BUSINESSMEN.
SO MOST OF THE NOTES FOUND WERE
FROM HUSBANDS TWO WIVES
FROM POLITICS TO CHILDREN.
TWO NOTES THAT I READ HAVE NEVER
LEFT ME.
ONE HUSBAND WROTE TO HIS WIFE
SIMPLY SAYING.
IT WAS A GOOD LIFE WITH YOU.
ONE FATHER WROTE TO HIS CHILDREN
SAYING.
PLEASE GROW UP. TO BE THE KIND
OF PERSON THAT PEOPLE WILL
LAUGH.
THEY CONDENSE THEIR DEEPEST LOVE
AND HOPE. INTO A SINGLE SENTENCE
WRITTEN FROM THEIR HEARTS.
IF WE WERE TOLD. THAT WE MIGHT
HAVE ONLY MINUTES TO LIVE.
WHO WOULD BE RIGHT TO?
AND WHAT WOULD WE WANT TO SEE.
LET THIS BE OUR THOUGHTFUL
REFLECTION AND REMINDER TO SHARE
FROM OUR HEARTS
OUR LOVE AND GRATITUDE AT EVERY
OPPORTUNITY.
NOW MORE ME DOWN.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND.
THANK YOU. PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR OUR FLAG SALUTE
TODAY'S PLEDGE WILL BE.
GIVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK.
READY BEGAN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
TWO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS.
NATION. PRODUCT. VISIBLE LIBERTY
AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY JANUARY
SECOND TWENTY EIGHTEEN PERCENT
TO THE PROVISIONS OF
RETROFITTING NICE TO CALDERON
MOVES TO MISTER DALY SECONDS OF
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DIM RED AND AMENDMENTS IN THE
DOTTED. MESSAGES IN THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE
.
TODAY'S ABSENCES FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER A
TRINITARIAN. FOR PATERNITY LEAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KEVIN MULLIN.
MR COUNTER ON YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND ALLOW SOMEONE.
GALLAGHER IN GIPSON TO SPEAK ON
AN ADJOURNMENT AND
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE NOTICE REMOVAL
OF ITEM A ONE AB FORTY SEVEN E.
JONES SAWYER FROM THE INACTIVE
FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
TODAY IN THE CHAMBER.
MR MAYES YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER BUT
MEMBERS.
IN THE LEADER'S CHARTER SCHOOL
AS A KINDERGARTEN THROUGH EIGHTH
GRADE SCHOOL FOUNDED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN IN THE HEART OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THEY IN THE CITY OF YUCAIPA.
THEIR PURPOSE IS TO INSPIRE A
NEW GENERATION OF STUDENTS
TRAINED TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE WITH
HONESTY INTEGRITY AND SERVICE
WHILE HOLDING TO HIGH STANDARDS
FOR ALL. I AM PROUD AND HONORED
TO WELCOME UP UP IN THE GALLERY
TODAY THE SEVENTH AND EIGHTH
GRADERS FROM IN THE LEADER'S
CHARTER SCHOOL PLEASE HELP ME
WELCOME THEM.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA. YOUR
RECOGNIZE FROM MR GRAY'S DESK.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS TODAY I
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY EMPLOYERS
YOUR TO PRESENT AND WELCOME NEAR
U. S. WEST COAST INNOVATION TOUR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY.
AS THE SIXTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD CALIFORNIA IS A
NATURAL.
COLLABORATIVE WITH THE U. AT THE
U. EU INNOVATION BASED
BUSINESSES.
THE ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE
WHICH I CHAIR AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT HAVE PULLED TOGETHER
A DAY A BRIEF SCENES AT THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT YOUR
SUCCESSFUL EXPANSION TO
CALIFORNIA.
NEAR U. S. IS COMMENDED FOR THE
OUTSTANDING CONTRIBUTIONS ITS
PROGRAM MAKE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE ENTIRE NATION
AND WE EXTEND OUR SINCERE BEST
WISHES FOR YOUR SUCCESS. UP
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME AND
WELCOMING OUR HONORED GUESTS
.
MR GRAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
PLEASE JOIN ME THIS MORNING IN
WELCOMING TO OUR CHAMBER THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF PATERSON IN
MY DISTRICT GOVERNOR BELLY AND
HER.
JOINING US UP.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU WELCOME VISITORS.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING THE CLERK THE
CLERK WILL READ.
AT SOME LEVEL TWELVE FORTY EIGHT
AND FIFTEEN TWENTY SIX.
ALL BILLS WILL BEGIN RENDON
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS THREE
THROUGH SIX ARE CAN.
WE ARE MOVING TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
ITEM TEN E. B. TWO EIGHTY TO THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO SUICIDE.
MISTER JONES SAWYER RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWO A TWO
WHICH IS REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A
TEN.
CLEAN UP TO THE STATUTE WOULD
MAKE TO THE FAMILY TO EIGHT
ADVISE OR ENCOURAGES SUICIDE
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
END OF LIFE OPTION. IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN TO PENAL CODE
PROVISION WHICH MAKES IT A CRIME
TO AID A SUICIDE WAS NOT UPDATED
TO REFLECT THAT CHANGE.
THIS BILL MAKES DID NECESSARY
CHANGES AND SPECIFIES THAT
ACTIONS WHICH ARE COMPLIANT WITH
THE END OF LIFE OPTION COULD NOT
BE PROSECUTED UNDER THE CRIMINAL
STATUTE. MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZE THE
CLERK WILL PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRING TO
VOTE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELE DEVOTES.
EYES FORTY ONE NO SIXTEEN THE
MOTION PASSES.
MOVING OUT ITEM ELEVEN AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR CONSOLIDATES
FLETCHER THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND ACTUALLY THE
CRIMINAL LAW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OF GONZALEZ
FLETCHER YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR WILL HELP PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN AND ADDRESS
UNINTENDED.
IT'S FROM A LEGAL LOOPHOLE IN
THE STANDARDS FOR COLLECTION OF
DNA.
CURRENT LAW UNDER PROPOSITION
SIXTY NINE SPECIFICALLY LIMITS A
COLLECTION OF DNA SAMPLES FROM
MINORS TO ONLY WHEN THEY HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED OF CERTAIN
SPECIFIED CRIMES SUCH AS A SEX
OFFENSE. OR FELONY.
HOWEVER THE PROPOSITION ALSO
CREATED LOOPHOLE WHERE SAMPLES
WHICH I ONLY SUBMITTED TO A
LOCAL DATABASE ARE NOT SUBJECT
TO THE SAME STANDARDS.
IN PRACTICE THIS IS ALLOWED LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN SAN DIEGO TO
BROADEN THEIR SCOPE OF THOSE
ELIGIBLE FOR COLLECTION OF DNA
SAMPLES AND OTHER JURISDICTIONS
COULD DO THE SAME.
THIS BILL BILL PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF.
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZE THE
CLERK WILL PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRING TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE A TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FOUR KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTEEN AB THREE
OF SIX GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
WITH AMENDMENTS
THE CLERK WILL REPLACE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OF SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
HARPER.
MISTER HARPER ON YOUR
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THE AUTHOR STATES ASSIST BILLS
BASED ON I WILL LONG. AND TO
IMPOSE A DEADLINE ON WHEN VOTERS
ARE TO COLLECT THEIR VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOTS.
FROM VOTERS WHO TURNED THEM IN
WITH ELECTION OFFICIALS.
THAT'S OUTLINED HERE IN THE US.
VOTER OR THE.
INFORMATION SHE ON THE BILL
PROVIDED BY THE AUTHOR HERSELF.
BUT TAKING ONLY ONE PORTION OF
THAT LAW IS MISLEADING.
THESE AMENDMENTS
WHATEVER UP THE REST OF THE IOWA
LAW THAT WAS LEFT OUT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
THEY WOULD REQUIRE PEOPLE TO
COLLECT VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS
FROM VOTERS.
TO PROVIDE A RECEIPT TO THE
VOTER UPON REQUEST IDENTIFYING
WHO IS PICKING UP THE BALLOT.
THESE AMENDMENTS WOULD PROUD
PROVISIONS TO PROTECT VOTERS TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR VOTE IS
COUNTED. AND NOT ONE VOTE IS
DISENFRANCHISED.
BY FAILING TO DELIVER THEIR
BALLOT TO ELECTION OFFICIALS.
WITHOUT THESE AMENDMENTS LAW
ENFORCED MEANT OFFICIALS WILL
HAVE NO WAY OF BEING ABLE TO
TRACK DOWN WHO FAILED TO DELIVER
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS.
IN THE FIRST ELECTION SINCE
BALLOT HARVESTING WAS LEGALIZED
THERE WERE PUBLISHED REPORTS OF
OVERLY AGGRESSIVE HARASSING VOTE
BY MAIL DESIGNEES.
COERCING VOTERS INTO HANDING
OVER THEIR BALLOTS.
IN RESPONSE TO THESE REPORTS THE
LOS ANGELES TIMES EDITORIAL
BOARD IN AN EDITORIAL ENTITLED
DON'T ALLOW VOTER COERCION AND
CORRUPTION.
TAKE HOLD IN CALIFORNIA OCALAN
MAKERS TO AN ACT VOTER
PROTECTIONS
AND IT SPECIFICALLY URGED US TO
RECONSIDER THE WISDOM OF
ALLOWING UNKNOWN THIRD PARTIES.
WITHOUT ANY IDENTIFICATION
WITHOUT ANY TRACKING OR ANY
RECEIPT TO COLLECT BALLOTS FROM
VOTERS.
BY ADOPTING THESE AMENDMENTS WE
CAN PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTIONS AND ENSURE THAT EVERY
VOTE IS COUNTED. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MR CALDERON YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
MAKING MENACE I MOVE TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE.
THANK YOU MR CALDERON MOVES AND
MISTER GIBSON SECONDS AT THE
AMENDMENTS BE LAID ON THE TABLE
THE MOTION IS NOT DEBATABLE.
CLARK PUT THE CLICK WILL PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE FAMILY MEMBER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HARPER IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
HARPER IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY EIGHT.
KNOWS TWENTY FOUR.
THE MEASURE FAILS START WITH THE
MOTION THE AMENDMENTS ARE LAID
ON THE TABLE.
BACK TO THE BILL THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME OF ALL THREE OF SIX BY SOME
THE NUMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND
ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER THANK YOU THIS
IS A VERY SIMPLE CLEAN UP BILL
LAST YEAR WE PASSED A A BILL
THAT SAID A VOTER CAN DECIDE WHO
CAN.
WE LET THE VOTER AND ADULTS MAKE
THE DECISION ON WHO THEY WANT TO
HAVE TURN IN THE BALLOT. AND IF
THEY DON'T HAVE A STAMP OR CAN'T
MAKE IT TO THE MAILBOX OR.
A FRIEND IS GOING TO GO TURN IN
A BALLOT THEY GET TO MAKE THAT
DECISION NOW A VERY ADULT
DECISION. I'M ALL THIS BILL DOES
IS SAY THAT PERSON SHOULD DO IT
WITH IN.
TWO DAYS
WE REALIZE AFTER THE BILL WAS
ENACTED.
THAT UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES THEY COULD HOLD
ONTO IT UNTIL ELECTION DAY WHICH
COULD BE UP TO THIRTY DAYS SO
THIS IS JUST AS A SIMPLE CLEAN
UP BILL IN ONE THAT I THINK
MAKES SENSE TO ALL OF US I
RESPECT LAST FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER HARPER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT AS I
POINTED OUT EARLIER. THE
EDITORIAL BY THE LOS ANGELES
TIMES ENTITLED DON'T ALLOW VOTER
CORRUPTION AND COERCION TO TAKE
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA. WAS VERY
CLEAR IN IDENTIFYING THAT THERE
WERE MULTIPLE PROBLEMS WITH THE
ORIGINAL BILL ALLOWING BALLOT
HARVESTING.
THIS IS NOT A FIX
THIS IS INCOMPLETE AND IT WOULD
BE A SHAM TO BE TELLING THE
VOTERS. THAT THIS WAS A FIX TO
THE CLEARLY IDENTICAL PROP
IDENTICAL PROBLEM OF COERCION.
CORRUPTION AS WELL AS
HARASSMENT.
IF LEFT UNCHECKED
THERE WILL BE NO PAPER TRAIL NO
WAY TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY.
PEOPLE WHO WERE INTERFERING WITH
THE BALLOT PROCESS IN NEGATIVE
IN NEFARIOUS WAYS.
WHETHER IT'S POLITICAL BOSSES.
WHETHER IT'S UNION BOSSES.
WEATHER IT'S ORGANIZED CRIME
BOSSES.
OR PERHAPS A BILLIONAIRE.
EMPLOYING A LEGION OF GOONS TO
COURSE BUT AND CORRUPT THE ELK
THE BALLOT PROCESS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE. THAT OUR
SYSTEM HAS THE INTEGRITY TO BE
ABLE TO SURVIVE INTO THE NEXT
DECADES INSTEAD OF GOING BACK TO
TAMMANY HALL STYLE CORRUPTION.
OF BIG CITY BALLOT BOXES.
MISS ONE DOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
SO THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF THIS
BILL I DID NOT VOTE FOR BECAUSE
I AGREE THAT IT COULD LEAD TO
BALLOT HARVESTING. AND CERTAINLY
POSE SOME PROBLEMS WITH OUR
ELECTIONS.
HOWEVER.
THIS BILL WHICH IS AN ATTEMPT
TO MAKE AFFECTS.
I WILL AGREE WITH THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER THAT I DON'T THINK IT
GOES FAR ENOUGH A RECEIPT WOULD
BE GREAT SOME SORT OF PROOF ONE
WITH THAT THIS WAS COLLECTED IN
BY HIM WOULD BE GREAT. THAT'S
NOT IN THIS BILL THAT DOES NOT
MAKE THIS BILL. UNSUPPORTABLE IN
MY ARMS.
SOMETIMES WE TO TAKE BABY STEPS
TO FIX THINGS.
WE CAN'T HAVE IT ALL AT ONCE
IT'S FRUSTRATING.
I SYMPATHIZE WITH YOU.
BUT DO WE SAY NO TO SOMETHING
THAT IS ATTEMPTING TO MAKE.
SMALL SPECKS ALBEIT NOT AS MUCH
AS WE WANT TO SAY NO TO THAT
BECAUSE WE CAN'T HAVE THE WHOLE
THING I THINK THAT'S A MISTAKE.
THERE ARE LOTS OF BILLS ARE LOTS
OF POLICIES AND LAWS A TO PUT IN
PLACE IN THIS HOUSE THAT WE
LATER.
MAKE SOME AMENDMENTS TO THAT WE
MAKE SOME FIXES TO WHETHER TO
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP WHATEVER IT
IS WE DO THAT ALL OF THE TIME.
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL.
.
AGAIN.
RESTATING.
MY COMMENT THAT
I DO SUPPORT THE BILL. IN THE
FIRST PLACE BUT I DON'T THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING HORRIBLE.
IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO MAKE A FIX
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER. ALLEN
DID YOU WANT TO BE RECOGNIZED.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RECEIVE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU ALL AND THANK MY
COLLEAGUE MIKE ELSINORE AND
ALLOW HER OUT CLOSING TO BE THE
CLOTHES.
I RESPECT LAST NIGHT. THANK YOU
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS BOTH THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY THREE KNOWS ONE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
UNDER ANNOUNCEMENTS WE ARE
MOVING TO MISTER LEVINE. FOR HIS
GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM SPEAKER
JUST CHECKING TO SEE IF OF MY
MAYOR AND COUNCILMEMBERS FOR
MARIN WERE UP HERE AND IN THE
GALLERY WE HAVE JUST ABOVE ME.
SAN ANSELMO COUNCILMEMBER BRIAN
COLE BEAR WHO IS NEWLY ELECTED
AND CITY MANAGER OF SAN ANSELMO
DAVID DONNER WHO ARE JOINING US
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WELCOMING.
MY CONSTITUENTS.
RETURNING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE WE MOVE TO ITEM
FIFTEEN ACR ONE FIFTY TWO.
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR
CURRY AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
PROCLAIMING NATIONAL MENTORING
MONTH.
IS THAT YOUR CURRY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I STAND TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS TO
PRESENT A SEA R. ONE FIFTY TWO.
THIS RESOLUTION DECLARES THE
MONTH OF JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AS MENTOR NATIONAL
MENTORING MONTH. AND SUNDAY THE
TWENTY FIRST AS THANK YOU MAN
MENTOR DAY.
MENTORING RELATIONSHIPS A
POWERFUL POSITIVE EFFECTS ON
YOUNG PEOPLE IN A VARIETY OF
PERSONAL ACADEMIC ATHLETIC AND
PROFICIENT PROFESSIONALS
SITUATIONS.
MENTORS BUILD CHARACTER
ENCOURAGE SUCCESS BOOST
CONFIDENCE IN EXPAND THE
UNIVERSE AS A CHILD OF A CHILD.
MOST OF US HERE HAVE BEEN
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE A FEW
MENTORS IN OUR LIVES.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT HOW MY
MENTORS OF HELP ME I AM FILLED
WITH GRATITUDE.
MY MENTOR WAS A WOMAN BY THE
NAME OF MARGARET BUCKMINSTER.
MARGARET WAS THE OTHER MOTHER IN
MY NEIGHBORHOOD.
MARGARET TAUGHT ME HOW TO A
COOK.
YOU COULD MAKE THE BEST COOKIES
IN THE WHOLE NEIGHBORHOOD SHOES
ALSO TAUGHT ME HOW TO SEW AND
SHE LET ME GO TO A PATH TO WORK
OF. WITH A A CALIFORNIA FOR H.
CLUB.
AND IN THE YEARS DURING FOUR
EIGHT SHE WOULD CART MYSELF AND
MY BEST FRIEND JANICE AND HER
SISTERS UP AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I COULD COMPETE IN
DEMONSTRATIONS.
AND SO EVERY DAY I KEEP THIS BY
MY DESK.
AND THIS IS MY VERY FIRST AWARD
IT WAS THE PRESENTED TO ME AND
ON MARCH THIRTIETH NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT MANY OF YOU WEREN'T
BORN YET.
BUT THIS IS MY VERY FIRST AWARD
REMINDS ME WHERE I CAME FROM.
SO GOD BLESS MET MARGARET BUST
MASTER AND THANK HER FOR ALL OF
WHERE I AM TODAY.
ACR A ONE FIFTY TWO REAFFIRMS
THE LEGISLATORS COMMITMENT TO
RECOGNIZING AND PROMOTING
MENTORS IN OUR COMMUNITY
STATEWIDE.
I LIKE TO OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SEVENTY FOUR CO
AUTHORS.
BY ACCLAMATION WE SHALL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
AYE ALL OPPOSED.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ALL OTHER ITEMS WILL BE PASSING
RETAINED.
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN THROUGH TENNEY TWENTY
WILL BE PASSED THE RETAINED.
WE'RE MOVING TWO ANNOUNCEMENTS
IN A GERMAN SOME MEMORY THIS
SESSION SCHEDULE IS OF THE AS IS
IS AS FOLLOWS JANUARY NINETEENTH
NO FLOOR SESSION NO CHECK IN
SESSION.
THAT WAS FRIDAY MONDAY JANUARY
TWENTY SECOND FLOOR SESSION AT
ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF AN OBJECTION
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED A GERMAN SOME MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A JOURNEY MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR THE ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY
FOR THE ATTORNEY MEMORIES
MISTER GALLAGHER YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
TERROR AN EVIL VISITED US ONCE
AGAIN. IN THE FORM OF ANOTHER
SENSELESS SHOOTING.
ON NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
A DEMENTED MAN WENT ON A RAMPAGE
TO THE SMALL COMMUNITY OF RANCHO
TO HIM.
IN MY DISTRICT.
THIS MAN AND I'M NOT GOING TO
USE HIS NAME.
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T DESERVE IT.
PROCEED TO GUN DOWN HIS WIFE.
HIS NEIGHBORS.
AND HIS FELLOW COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
BEFORE PROCEEDING TO A SCHOOL.
WHERE HE IGNORED THE GUN FREE
ZONE?
AND WALKED ON THE CAMPUS WITH
THE INTENT OF KILLING OUR MOST
INNOCENT.
I THINK GOD FOR THE FAST ACTING
TEACHERS AND STAFF.
WHO LOCK DOWN THE CLASSROOMS AS
SOON AS THEY HEARD THE FIRST
SHOTS FIRED?
IS BECAUSE OF THEIR HEROIC
EFFORTS.
THEIR LIVES WERE SAVED THAT DAY.
THE GUNMAN COULDN'T GET IN.
BUT IT DIDN'T STOP HIM FROM
FIRING INTO THE CLASSROOMS.
WOUNDING A SIX YEAR OLD BOY.
ALEJANDRO.
LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONDED AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND THEY FINALLY DISPATCH THE
GUNMEN IN A SHOOTOUT.
THERE WERE OTHER HEROES THAT DAY
AS WELL THE MAN CREDITED WITH
DISTRACTING THE GUNMEN FROM THE
SCHOOL.
AND A MOTHER.
WHO PROTECT THE LIVES OF HER
THREE CHILDREN?
LET US REMEMBER THE VICTIMS
TODAY.
THERE'S A BOY GAUGE.
WHOSE WITHOUT HIS GRANDMOTHER
AND FATHER TODAY.
DANNY ELLIOTT SECOND WAS THIRTY
EIGHT WAS A DEVOTED FATHER AND
LOVING FRIEND.
DANNY WOULD GIVE THE SHIRT OFF
HIS BACK.
IF IT MEANT HELPING SOMEONE
ELSE.
DAN STEELE WAS SIXTY EIGHT.
AS THE MOTHER OF DANIELLE IT
ENGAGES GRANDMOTHER WHOM HE
LOVED.
A MAN WALKS TODAY WITHOUT HIS
BELOVED WIFE.
CHAU MCFAYDEN FIFTY FIVE.
WAS A CHILD PROTECTIVE OFFICER
WORKED WITH TROUBLED KIDS.
SHE HAD A SPUNKY PERSONALITY AND
ALWAYS WENT ABOVE AND BEYOND FOR
OTHERS.
I GOT TO SPEAK WITH HER HUSBAND
TROY.
RECENTLY IN CHOI TOLD ME.
ABOUT MICHELLE AND HER
DEDICATION TO HER JOB.
TWO YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND THAT SHE DIDN'T DESERVE IT.
SHE DIDN'T DESERVE THIS.
AND SHE DID NOT.
JOSEPH MCCUE THE SECOND FIFTY
SIX.
WAS A FARMER WHO MOVED A
CALIFORNIA TO BE WITH HIS
NEPHEW.
HE WAS DESCRIBED AS A QUIET MAN
AND A HARD WORKER.
BARBARA GIL SAN THIRTY EIGHT.
WAS A WOMAN WHO LOVE DOGS AND
ANIMALS AND WORKED.
AT THE LOCAL PIZZA SHOP.
MEMBERS WE STAND HERE IN THE
WAKE OF YET ANOTHER SENSELESS
ACT.
I CAN'T MAKE SENSE OF IT.
OTHER THAN TO THE POINT.
TO THE EVIL THAT WE KNOW LURKS
IN THE HEARTS OF MEN.
DESPITE ALL OUR PHILOSOPHY
ENLIGHTENMENT.
OUR SOCIAL WORK EVIL STILL
EXISTS.
AND IT REMAINS OUR DUTY TO
FERRET OUT.
IN CARRYING OUT THIS UNSPEAKABLE
ACT.
THE GUNMAN USE ILLEGALLY
CONSTRUCTED SEMI AUTOMATIC
RIFLE.
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS PRETTY.
PROHIBITED.
FROM POSSESSING ANY FIREARM DUE
TO RESTRAINING ORDER THAT HAVE
BEEN ISSUED AGAINST HIM. IN
FEBRUARY OF THE SAME YEAR.
BUT AS WE KNOW ALL TOO WELL NOW.
FROM SAN BERNARDINO.
SANTA BARBARA.
TO NOW RANCHO TO HIM.
CRIMINALS.
TERRORISTS.
AND THE MENTALLY INSANE.
DON'T FOLLOW OUR LAWS.
TODAY WE REMEMBER THE VICTIMS
BUT I HOPE WE WILL DO MORE.
WE'VE DONE MUCH TO DISARM OUR
CITIZENRY.
BUT HAVE WE DONE ENOUGH.
TO DISARM.
CRIMINALS.
AND THE INSANE.
WE CAN DO BETTER.
IT WE CAN DO BETTER TO PROTECT
OUR SCHOOLS.
IN OUR CHURCHES.
THERE TO BECOME THE ULTIMATE
SOFT TARGETS.
TODAY I ASK YOU TO ADJOURN IN
THE SACRED NAMES.
OF THESE VICTIMS
BUT I ALSO ASK YOU.
STAND WITH ME.
TO HELP BETTER PROTECT OUR
CITIZENS.
OUR KIDS.
OUR PARISHIONERS.
FROM THE EVIL THAT WE KNOW
EXISTS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
Q. MISTER GALLAGHER.
MISTER GIBSON YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARE RISE TO
* BODY TO ADJOURN AT THE
MEMORY.
OF ARTURO DID DO NAIR FRAZIER.
OUR TRUE WAS BORN FEBRUARY THERE
TWELFTH NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
AND WAS RAISED IN COMPTON
CALIFORNIA.
HE GREW UP ATTENDING LOCAL
SCHOOLS HE WORKED VERY BROAD HE
WORKED OF VERY HEAVILY AN
INVOLVED IN THE COMMUNITY OF
CONTENT.
DURING HIS EARLY YEARS HE
WORKERS THE LAYERS ON FOR THEN.
CITY BECAUSE OF COMPTON CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER IS A DOOR HALL
THE THIRD.
HE WAS TRULY STRAIGHT OUT OF
COMPTON.
HE ALSO WAS THE PROJECT MANAGER
FOR THEIR TEACHING INITIATIVE
FOR THE LOS ANGELES URBAN LEAGUE
AND WAS A FIELD REPRESENTATIVE
FOR FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER STEVEN
BRADFORD OF THE SIXTY SECOND
DISTRICT.
HIS PASSION FOR COMMUNITY WAS A
WAS A NOW ONLY IN POLITICS BUT
ALSO IN THE COMMUNITY AND IT
SHOW.
EACH AND EVERY DAY THAT HE TRY
VERY HARD TO MAKE PEOPLE'S LIVES
BETTER IN THE COMMUNITY.
WHILE SERVING IN POLITICS FOR
THE PAST TWELVE YEARS.
ARTURO WAS ALSO THE YOUTH
PASTOR AT THE.
MOUNT PILGRIM MISSIONARY
BAPTIST CHURCH LOCATED IN
COMPTON AS WELL.
HE LEFT.
US VERY SOON.
AT THE AGE OF THIRTY NINE YEARS
OLD ON PASSED AWAY.
ON DECEMBER THE TENTH DUE TO A
CAR ACCIDENT HE WAS DOING WHAT
HE ENJOYED DOING AND HE WAS
COMING FROM CHURCH.
AS HE CROSSED THE STREET
AND A CAR HIT HIM AND KILLED
HIM.
ARTURO LEAVES TO CHERISH HIS
MEMORY HIS MOTHER.
S. FATHER HIS GRANDMOTHER SISTER
AND MANY FRIENDS AND FAMILY WHO
ARE TORO TOUCH OF THEIR LIVES.
MEMBERS I CERTAINLY WOULD ASK
YOU TO PLEASE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF ARTURO FRAZIER THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES TO THE DESK TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL REQUEST RICHARD A MEMORY
WILL BE JIM READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MISTER CALDERON MOVES
MISS RUBIO SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY JANUARY TECH TWENTY
SECOND AT ONE PM